this is what's left of the once bustling
village of solhan
a group of armed men attacked on friday
night
shooting people and burning down their
homes in what's been described
as a massacre burkina faso's prime
minister
traveled to the remote village near the
border with niger to see what happened
this is the first time our country has
experienced an attack with such massive
destruction to the people of our country
and from this point of view the
president wanted us to spread the
message of hope
we have been fighting against terrorism
for some time we have won some victories
but each time there are new challenges
that arise
the situation in salon is a new
challenge for us
dabire also visited a hospital where
dozens of the injured were taken
several shared stories of the horror
they witnessed
there was so much damage they killed so
many people without even separating the
woman and children
they killed they burned all the goods
they saw
they ransacked the prime minister says
the attack will not go unpunished and
that extra forces have been deployed to
the region
he was joined by defence minister sharif
momenta
who last month promised to step up the
fight against armed groups
but burkina faso's military is seen as
ill-equipped and under-trained
and is facing an increasing number of
attacks as well as ethnic and religious
tension
no one's claimed responsibility for
friday's violence
but analysts believe it was likely
carried out by a group linked to
al-qaeda
particularly
since the arrival of terrorism 2015 this
is the first time that there have been
so many deaths in a single operation
and above all so many civilian deaths
this is why the burkinabe population is
very sad and questions about the ability
of the country
and the defense and security system to
stem the terrorist insurgency are
growing the prime minister says seven
thousand families were displaced by the
latest fighting
adding to the more than one million
who've been forced from their homes in
the past two years
he says the community must work with the
government to ensure
young people aren't recruited by armed
groups
our youth need to stay in the country to
work towards economic and social
development
it's not good to let these young people
leave they're recruited by terrorist
groups and return to villages to bring
terror and sadness to their own families
burkina faso was once seen as a stable
country in the turbulent sahel region
but that reputation has now been
shattered alexi o'brien al jazeera